welcome to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron cousins from Maria buyer sitting
in once again today for David Packman and
today I wanted
to start the show with a little bit of good
news because most of the stuff we have to
discuss as either terrifying were depressing.
So let's begin with something positive.
And the positive comes in the form of new
poll numbers showing that roughly 40% of expected
voters for 2020 40% rate climate change as
a top issue, not the top issue, but 40% say
that they are strongly going to consider a
candidate stance on climate change before
casting a ballot in 2020 and that is up 5%
from the 2016 numbers.
When only about 35% of the country said that
climate change was going to impact their vote.
So those numbers are going up.
They're going up slowly, but they are up and
that is always a positive 40% it's not even
half.
I understand that, but that is encouraging.
Finally, we have at least 40% of the country
as a whole.
The eligible voters as a whole who understand
that climate change is one of the most important
issues facing this country today.
Not any of these made up scenarios from politicians.
It's not the threat of Irfan.
It's not the threat of people coming across
the border.
It's an actual real threat that scientists
have been warning us about for decades.
And that is obviously climate change.
Now the numbers get a little bit skewed when
you break it down by party.
Um, you, uh, with the Democrats, you have
about 76% say that climate change is important
to their vote, a little over 30% for independence.
And then of course we're hovering around 10%
for Republicans.
Those numbers on the lower end, obviously
not exactly what we want to see, but we can
take a little bit of time to be happy about
the fact that hey, at least 10% of Republicans
say climate change is important.
And to be honest, that that 10 to 12% is actually
pretty good.
Considering the fact that conservative media
routinely tells us, tells their audience that
climate change does not exist, that it's some
kind of liberal hoax, that the planets just
in one of those warming slash cooling cycles
that happens, all the or that a snowball in
DC somehow disproves what scientists had been
saying for decades.
So 10% may seem small, but when you consider
the amount of misinformation that the right
absorbs on a daily basis, 10% ain't that bad,
folks, I think we should be happy about that.
And here's the another reason why we need
to be happy about these 40% as a whole numbers.
And that is because this is an issue that
we still have time to fix.
Nothing is set in stone yet and that is one
of the big things that climate scientists
have been encouraging people to talk about
when they talk about climate change.
We can't talk all gloom and doom.
We're done.
The planet's dead.
No, they said we have to remind people that
there is still time.
Because if we do talk in those terms of, Oh,
we've burned the planet down, nothing we can
do, then yeah, people lose hope and they stopped
caring about it.
They just say, okay, well this is what it
is.
Nothing I can do.
I'm not going to change my ways.
I'm not going to call for action.
We're doomed, but that's not the truth.
We have time.
We have plenty of time.
To be perfectly honest with you, it's just
that we have leaders in this country and other
leaders abroad who were not doing enough and
it is our job to push them to do more, and
that is why the 40% number is so important
because if we act fast, if we stay on top
of this issue, we can do something about it.
We can change the future, but if we put another
climate change denier into the White House,
if we put somebody in the White House who
is squarely in the pocket of the fossil fuel
industry, the nothing's going to change and
we're going to lose another four years on
this very important issue.
We may not have four years to lose.
I know, uh, at the end of last year, we got
the report saying we had about 12 years before
we see the irreparable damages from climate
change, but that's been six months.
So we're at 11 and a half years now.
Get that number 12 out of your brain.
We've lost six months.
We can make up for it.
We have the technology costs of renewable
energy are now coming down.
It's actually more affordable than fossil
fuels.
We need the infrastructure in place.
So look for that in candidates, especially
on the democratic side, obviously in their
climate plans, because without that renewable
energy infrastructure, all the windmills,
all the solar farms, all of that isn't going
to mean that much if we, if we do not have
a viable delivery system.
Now, that's another thing that a lot of people
don't seem to understand.
It's like, yeah, just switched to renewables.
We could have done that and we could have
built out this infrastructure 10 years ago,
15 years ago, started building it out.
But unfortunately that didn't happen.
So we are behind the curve on this, right?
We have lot of work to do, but those who are
saying that the technology simply doesn't
exist.
Or if you listen to the president who tells
you that, oh, when the wind doesn't blow and
you're on wind power, you don't watch TV that
night, that's a lie.
Battery capacity is up.
Uh, delivery systems have evolved and if we
put them in place, we absolutely as a country
could do this.
We could have been a leader on this issue
of climate change and renewable energy, but
instead we felt in the back of the pack and
we're now having to play catch up to all of
the other countries in the world who are meeting
their emissions reduction marks while the
US has blown way past hours.
But 40% is a good number, not as good as we
would like it.
But at this point you got to take every little
victory that you can and 40% saying climate
change is going to influence
their vote.
That
is a good number.